So what was unethical by today's standards however was when Milgram told
participants that they had no choice but to continue in the research even when
they didn't want to. Now to be fair to Milgram he was not breaking any rules
because there were no rules at the time about how to treat participants and
what they could and couldn't do. But in fact as a result of Milgram's study,
those rules came into existence as guidelines. Now, remember from lesson two
that the essence of these guidelines are first, that every participant sign a
consent form. Every participant be told in this consent form that they can
withdraw at any time, without penalty, and finally, that every participant be
told afterwards what the study was about. And that is, debriefed.